materials are marvelous they can be your
friend or they can be your enemy today
I'd like to talk to you a little bit
about why Napoleon would not think that
all materials are so Menefee hi my name
is Aneesa Ramirez welcome to science
explained and to Yale's west campus the
year 2012 is a 200th year anniversary of
Napoleon's invasion into Russia in 1812
it was a failed campaign Napoleon went
in with 600,000 men and returned with
10,000 men that's less than 2% that
returned why was this such an ill-fated
campaign well Napoleon had to fight the
elements one of the elements was a cold
Russian winter must have been very
unpleasant to fight under those
conditions the other element that he had
to fight was tin which was one of the
major ingredients in the buttons that
were used in the uniforms they were used
to hold pants up and to keep coats
closed now you may not know this but tin
undergoes a change when temperatures get
lowered at our temperature tin is a nice
shiny metal
however when tin experiences
temperatures that are lower than 56
degrees Fahrenheit or 13 degrees Celsius
tin turns to dust so legend has it that
Napoleon's army was foiled by buttons
these buttons fell and turned into dust
causing probably the world's greatest
wardrobe malfunction now whether that's
true or not the legend says that this is
the case but we certainly know about is
that tin is very important for our lives
today tin is a major and component for
solder and solder is a glue that holds
electronics together so anything that
has an on/off button like a cell phone
laptop computer has solder in it and has
tin in it and since it's so important
for our technologies it's so important
that people who mine it control it and
so there's lots of conflicts about this
material and lots of wars in efforts to
control how this material flows
in fact tin has the unusual designation
as being a conflict material because
it's related to human suffering
so you see materials are not static
objects they have impact and they can be
the center of conflict both old and new
I'm an ISA Ramirez thank you for joining
me at science explained and I hope that
you'll join us for another edition